[Music]
on this sunday night
breaking her silence the woman accusing
canada's former top
general of an inappropriate relationship
speaks out could i say no to him
no why she's sharing her story in a
global news exclusive
canadian students studying abroad now
forced to pay for a quarantine hotel
most students have nothing to their name
the calls to expand
the exemption list the disaster in texas
food banks run out and power bills
skyrocket
plus saving the whales new rules to
protect an endangered species
in atlantic canada
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us one of the women accusing canada's
former top
soldier of inappropriate behavior is
speaking out
kelly brennan is a major in the military
and jonathan vance was her boss
in an exclusive interview with mercedes
stevenson she claims she was involved in
a long-standing
intimate relationship with him which has
resulted in a military investigation
kelly brennan is a soldier he's a
woman and
i want to say she's a warrior with lots
of scars
after years of struggling kelly brennan
says she's now ready to tell her story
a major in the canadian forces brennan
says she had a long-standing
inappropriate and intimate relationship
with general jonathan vance
canada's former top soldier the two were
sexually involved brennan says
while vance was her boss and while he
was the chief of the defense staff
the same time he was publicly leading an
aggressive mission to stamp out sexual
misconduct in the military
known as operation honor this will take
time
but we are determined despite the public
proclamations about equality
brennan says there was a power imbalance
in the relationship
was i participating in it yes could i
say no to him
no and the reason why i say that is
because
if he rang me on the phone or if he
texted me i was obliged to get back to
him
if he asked to see me i had to drop
tools and see him
brennan says vance called her repeatedly
after global news broke the story
earlier this month
telling her to cover up the sexual
nature of the relationship
he gave me barriers when i could say
what that yes i could say that we had a
relationship engaged on
no i couldn't say that we had a
relationship after that
that we were just friends he was giving
me what to say
and i kept on asking him don't you
understand you're asking me to lie
vance is now under investigation by
military police
he has denied all accusations of
inappropriate behavior
and denies he told brennan to lie
brennan says she hopes her story will
shed light on the barriers victims of
sexual misconduct face
in the military and expose hypocrisy at
the highest levels of command
she says that she told vance while he
was leading canada's military
about a violent sexual assault she
experienced at the hands
of another canadian forces member but
that nothing
was done and i conveyed all of this to
john vance
in detail and he did nothing
so he he knew about this after operation
honor
and he did nothing nothing because he
couldn't he said
he couldn't why because he i was telling
him i was the dirty secret
he couldn't he couldn't defend me then
people would know about us
vance denies brennan told him about the
sexual assault
but brennan says her story goes beyond
vance
a symptom of a deeper problem plaguing
canada's military
she says some senior military officials
were complicit
looking the other way when vance abused
his authority over her
brennan hopes that by coming forward the
brass will finally take things seriously
they have no clue the reason is women
don't have a voice
we're not at the table robin the
allegations have shaken the canadian
military
where vance had championed an end to
sexual misconduct
and even created a new way to kick
people out of the forces
for inappropriate sexual behavior along
with the military police investigation
vance also faces
an independent external investigation
global news reached out to vance for
comment but we did not receive a
response by our deadline
robin mercedes stevenson in ottawa
new travel restrictions take effect as
of midnight tonight
anyone flying into canada must
quarantine for up to three days in a
hotel on
a designated list but as abigail beamon
explains many complain the price tag
and the tight rules are unfair
boris statnikov lives alone in israel
his wife died last year
he's recovering from double hip surgery
and he needs his son's help
three days additional
those restrictions they don't have the
government doesn't help in this case at
all
it's just that another gordon dmitry
statnikov will travel from ontario as
soon as israel opens its borders
but he's not pleased about the up to two
thousand dollar cost to stay in a hotel
when he returns
saying he also has his own health issues
that make eating delivered food
impossible his wife a health care worker
questions the medical necessity of a
hotel quarantine
in canada it's the land of immigrants
it's a eventually something happens and
you just need to go
not because you want to spend a week in
florida
it's really because you need to take
care of your family
as of sunday at one minute to midnight
all returning international air
travelers will have to quarantine until
they get a negative test result
which could take up to three days the
government has approved 14 designated
hotels so far
our government has been extremely clear
that very few exemptions will be
consented to and they're really related
to essential travelers
it was very inconvenient having to wait
on hold for three hours
it took travel expert claire newell that
long to get through on the government's
booking line
some sort of sustainable or reasonable
approach for those who
are on work visas or international
students
and those who are vaccinated none of
those have been addressed
international students like gabby
bolding facing an expiring visa in
scotland
after launching this petition and going
public with her story
someone offered to pay her hotel bill
she's still advocating for others
most students have nothing to their name
and financially throwing on something
like that that they haven't planned for
is extremely difficult especially to
people that
don't have the choice to get out of it
travelers entering by land
do not need to stay in a hotel but there
are new rules for them too in addition
to the coveted test results they have to
present at the border
starting monday they also need to take
two more tests one upon arriving
and another 10 days later in quarantine
they'll be given a test kit with
instructions and a courier will pick it
up
the federal government is paying for
that robin
abigail bayman in ottawa thanks abigail
indigenous communities remain vulnerable
to the virus because they live in remote
areas with fewer hospitals
the federal government reports more than
19 thousand cases of coven 19 on first
nations reserves
since the pandemic began there are still
more than 1200
active cases canada is almost a year
into this pandemic and there are
communities still
struggling to access a reliable supply
of personal protective equipment
a grassroots organization out of ottawa
is doing what it can to help
even if it means going into debt morgan
campbell reports
they are scenes that resemble
underdeveloped nations but they are from
right here in canada dilapidated homes
with
unsafe drinking water little to no
access to food
and health care we are very scared kathy
brady
helps to manage matawa first nation the
tribal council
oversees nine communities in northern
ontario
many of which are so remote you can only
fly
in and out if we get the virus that's
one thing
but the access to health care is is a
whole other issue
we're making more soup while indigenous
communities do their best to protect
their elders
and knowledge keepers creating a
stockpile of personal protective
equipment
has been a challenge since the beginning
of the pandemic more than 200
on reserve first nations people have
died from the virus
indigenous based advocacy groups fear
remote areas
are being overlooked access to care and
the inequalities have just
really demonstrated themselves in a real
way
right now sent on planes and in the back
of vehicles hope arrives
inside of these boxes a newly formed
volunteer organization has shipped more
than 1.5 million masks
and other ppe to indigenous communities
in five provinces
we are struggling to meet the demand
right and i hate turning people away
relying solely on donations
even doctors are assisting with the
initiative
we can have a two-tiered system where
some people get certain
resources and services and other people
don't
based on race because that's called
apartheid i just got the vaccine today
the federal government says 83 thousand
covid19 vaccine doses have been
administered
in more than 400 first nations that is
great but it puts us in a very
precarious position
that is because variants pose a serious
risk
upping the need for medical grade ppe
vio says it has gone deep into debt
in an effort to help some of the
country's most vulnerable
i just needed to get the ppe out
right i just needed these communities to
feel safe morgan campbell global news
toronto
in israel kofi 19 restrictions are being
eased after a two-month nationwide
lockdown
most schools museums and markets are now
open
the country's health ministry has
introduced a program called the green
badge for those who have had
two doses of the vaccine the past gives
them access to gyms
pools and restaurants it also allows
them to fly abroad
israel has conducted the world's
speediest vaccine campaign
nearly half its population has received
one vaccine dose
and nearly three million have had two
shots
the british government is speeding up
its vaccine efforts
the uk is now aiming to give every adult
their first dose
by july 31st that's a month earlier than
the previous target
the country's health secretary says the
plan is to give partial protection
to as many people as possible we will be
offering a vaccine to all those who are
over 50 and in the top nine priority
groups by the 15th
of april and then to all adults by the
end of july
the second dose will be delayed by 12
weeks the early success of britain's
vaccination program is welcome news in
the country
it has had more than 120 000 kova 19
related deaths
the highest in europe coming up
engine failure the frightening moments
on board and on the ground
and no relief for texas where the food
banks are running out of necessities
it's got a blown engine oh no
a terrifying moment in the sky and on
the ground
u.s transportation officials are
investigating what caused the
catastrophic
engine failure on board a boeing 777
that sent plane parts raining down on a
denver suburb
united airlines flight 328 bound for
honolulu took off
smoothly it was just 40 kilometers away
from the airport when pilots made the
mayday call
and turned back passengers say the plane
had just reached 10
000 feet when the engine blew
everything started well and then all of
a sudden it was just this
big you could just feel it like boom and
you could hear it and you just
we started shaking i did see some debris
flying at us where we were sitting
and i just thought i don't i don't know
if i want to know how bad this is i just
hope we get down
airlines has now grounded 24 of its
planes that have the same engines
the engine in question is the pratt and
whitney 4000 series
the power is back in most parts of texas
tonight but millions of americans are
still facing a critical shortage
of clean drinking water and food last
week a powerful blast of winter weather
cracked pipes froze wells
and knocked out water treatment plants
as jennifer johnson explains
the state's governor is promising an
investigation into why the deep freeze
plunged texas
into chaos as texas starts to thaw out
and power is restored to millions
its governor is pledging an
investigation into ercot the privately
owned corporation that manages almost
all of the state's power grid
and he's promising power generators will
be winterized to prevent future cold
weather outages
even if it means the state stepping up
providing funds to ensure that all of
the machinery
that froze up and was unable to generate
the power you need
that may require funding but right now
texans are facing a new challenge
getting drinking water after pipes burst
and systems were contaminated with
bacteria i'm under a boil notice too in
fort worth
but i have no water coming in my home
whatsoever i've got six little ones that
i need to take care of
president joe biden approved a disaster
declaration for 77 texas counties
providing federal money and assistance
as of last
night we had ordered 9.9 million bottles
of water
through our federal partners without
electricity many stores have also run
out of food
food banks have been packed restaurants
helping too this owner cooked hot meals
for anyone in dallas who needed them
all i did was put out the call saying
hey i need help they said we'll be there
and some texans who had opted to go with
cheaper variable rate power plans
not fixed rate ones are facing
skyrocketing bills
some already charged twenty thousand
dollars for the month megan o'neill's
power bill has been
one thousand dollars a day it's like
okay do i feed my family
or do i run the heat which one do i do
that's absolutely outrageous
and i know that that the the state house
will be looking into this when they come
into
into session the massive winter storm
caused at least 70 deaths
and thousands remain without power in
other states too including louisiana and
mississippi
but texas took the brunt of mother
nature's wrath president biden plans to
visit the state
this week to assess the crisis jennifer
johnson
global news washington still ahead the
vatican's new view
on vaccines
one year after italy's first case of
coppa 19 a memorial service was held at
a church in cadonio
to mark the anniversary the town was one
of many communities that locked down for
weeks early last year during early
attempts to stop the virus from surging
out of control
since then italy has seen 2.8 million
cases
and over 95 000 deaths vatican city is
easing back from a decree on coven 19
vaccination
in the face of heavy criticism earlier
this month the head of the city-states
government suggested employees who
refuse to get vaccinated
without a valid medical reason could be
fired
as redmond shannon reports the
controversy reflects a difficult dilemma
faced by employers around the world
ash wednesday in a pandemic
strict social distancing inside saint
peter's basilica
with only pope francis allowed to go
without a mask
the same event in 2020 saw huge crowds
and just a few masks a reminder of the
tragedy
that was soon to befall italy
earlier this month the pontiff stressed
the importance of global fraternity to
help
fight covet 19.
along with vaccinations he has been a
vocal supporter of equal access to shots
across the world even opening doors at
the holy see to give homeless people
the vaccine the pope's words came on a
day when the head of the vatican
government
cardinal giuseppe bertello issued a
decree on vaccines
it implied that any vatican employee who
refused a vaccine without a legitimate
health reason
could be fired it sparked a backlash in
italy
the vatican later clarifying that no one
would lose their job
i suspect that the impulse for this um
came from pope francis
if not directly it's certainly
indirectly this
notion of care for all of humanity
theologian michael atridge says the push
for vatican vaccines could be more about
the wider flock particularly amid
concerns that
some vaccine research uses cell lines
replicated from aborted fetuses
catholics around the world will also be
looking to
the pope and other church leaders to
know what to do
around vaccinations it's difficult to
balance out
sort of the rights of individuals
individual rights and freedoms on the
one hand
and the common good that dilemma is
starting to become apparent to employers
across the world mandating the vaccine
where it is not mandated countrywide
is close to impossible giving incentives
rather than threats
could also be tricky but you can't turn
around and say that those who are
vaccinated get to come into work
and those who are not have to stay home
and there's more perks and benefits
available to those who are vaccinated
that's called prejudicial treatment
ottawa and the provinces
say covert 19 vaccines will remain
voluntary
at least for now redmond shannon global
news london
farmers in india aren't letting up on
their protests against changes to the
country's agriculture laws
police in punjab state say more than a
hundred thousand people
attended this rally the farmers argue
the new laws won't guarantee them a
minimum price for their crops
the government of prime minister
narendra modi insists the policy changes
are needed to deregulate the agriculture
industry
and modernize the economy the standoff
has persisted for more than six months
up next finding the balance between the
fishing industry and an endangered
species
there are fewer than 400 north atlantic
right whales
in the world and in canada federal
efforts to protect them are proving
successful
over a five-year period 25 of the
majestic mammals died
after becoming entangled in fishing gear
or being struck by vessels
last year there were none ross lord
looks at the restrictions that balances
saving the whales
and allowing the fishing industry to
keep doing business
when it comes to saving animals that
could become extinct
the new set of rules surrounding right
whales are a lot like the old ones
the government is renewing speed limits
for cargo ships
and closing fishing zones where the
whales are seen or heard
but crab and lobster zones could reopen
sooner
unlike previous years they won't stay
closed unless surveillance indicates
they should
determining if whales remain present in
closed areas before deciding to extend
it a closure
then he runs through a crab industry
hopes the change gives fishers a better
chance to reach their
allowable catch it's a step in the good
direction for us
everybody has to remember that last year
there was about 12 percent
of the quote the crab quota that remain
in the water this right whale researcher
hopes
the animals can still avoid fishing gear
and ship strikes
like they did last year when there were
no reported deaths
i'm pleased that they're sort of holding
the line keeping their foot to the pedal
and and i hope that they're prepared to
act if if things start to turn
bad again this year brilliant says a
reported 15 right whale births this
winter is encouraging
but he fears the most recent population
estimate
366 shows the species is still in big
trouble
that's because they're at the mercy of
cargo ships and fishing boats
like they were when the government first
imposed restrictions
in two thousand seventeen the first
reaction from the fishermen
say well they're gonna disappear anyway
so you don't
quite care lenten suggests education has
helped harvesters switch
from adversaries to allies they also
have a financial incentive
an american law that could [ __ ] their
seafood exports to the u.s
if canada is found to be mistreating
marine mammals
ross lord global news
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada features these
dazzling displays and snow sculptures
from edmonton's annual silver skate
festival which is wrapping
up tonight we would love to see your
corner of the country so please
keep sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be back at the anchor desk tomorrow
i'll see you next weekend good night
[Music]
you